what are you doing hard times so I got a
really great question for one of my
YouTube viewers love you guys
Aviv one two three six five four who
wrote in to say hello I'm a new
subscriber to your channel welcome
aboard and I have a question for you
what do you do in hard times how to get
over that fast thank you this is a
fantastic question and one that I think
everybody can relate to as we've all
been through hard times I have three
bits of advice that I hope can help you
jump out of this present situation
number one is don't look for a quick fix
I think it's human nature that when we
have a problem we want to find a really
quick answer and we have a knee-jerk
reaction to try to solve it and often we
make the wrong decision so for example
if you're deep in debt and you say I've
got to find some money I gotta work my
way out of this and have some make a
quick buck you often end up jumping in
on a get-rich-quick kind of scheme and
you end up being deeper in debt and
deeper in the hole than when you started
or say you got out of a relationship and
you're feeling a hole in your heart that
you want to be with somebody often what
happens is you want to jump back in and
start dating and get into another
relationship and often that's the wrong
thing to do so don't have a knee-jerk
reaction don't try to solve this right
away because it's not gonna happen
instantly for you and that's okay number
two is find something to believe in hope
was a really powerful thing belief is a
really powerful thing that can give you
the adrenaline the encouragement the
drive to go out and accomplish things
that nobody else would think it's
possible for you to do even the former
you might think there's no way you can
go and do that you have to come up with
something that gets you excited finally
that makes you come alive and especially
when you're soaked down in that hole
getting out of it we'll start with you
believing in something important it
starts with you understanding that you
have an important role to play in making
the world a better place and adding
value to people's lives and then you
believe it in something so much and you
could take action every single day to
move forward on your goal you need to
get some momentum back in your life so
think about what you love doing think
about what you're passionate about think
about how you can help people and think
of how you can translate that into your
life right now
whether it's working for somebody else
or creating your own business you need
to have something that brings you hope
that gets you believing again and that
gets you excited again and number three
is create a supportive environment
chances are your garment sucks right now
everything from the people in your life
to the magazines your reading the TV
shows that you're watching everything
around you is keeping you in place it's
those people and things in your
environment that got you where you are
in the first place instead of living a
life by accident and being reactionary
to the things in your environment you
want to be proactive in creating a
supportive environment that builds you
up so start with our routine what do you
start with your day with to help add
some belief to your life to get you
excited to go out and start
accomplishing your goals and then
eliminate all the people and things in
your life that just tear you down
they'll keep you thinking small
they keep you thinking that you can't
accomplish what you set up to accomplish
and instead replace them with people
with things with videos with books that
build you up that make you believe that
give you confidence that make you want
to get out there and start doing things
I know it's tough being in the hole and
feeling like there's no way out and
feeling like you have more value to give
to the world than what is currently
happening right now to you I know that
we've all been there every single person
that you've talked to has been in that
situation where they feeling down on
themselves where they're down on their
luck and they don't know how to bust out
of it just remember that often people's
biggest successes come after they've hit
rock bottom they get monumental goals
and achieve great things after hitting
literally the bottom of the barrel so if
you do those three things of not looking
for a quick fix
finding something to believe in and then
creating a supportive environment you
too could be on your way to breaking out
of your hard times I hope that helped
answer your question thank you for
sharing and I hope you're on your way
now to getting closer to where you want
to be and believe for those of you
watching I love to hear how you've
gotten out of hard times or if you're in
a hard time right now share it in the
comments below
I'd love to get a conversation going I'm
gonna join in there with you thank you
so much for watching subscribe to the
channel if you wanna see more videos
like this and I'll see you soon
even your new literally totally not
secret I look forward to them every week
they have changed my life
thank you
you